Ось ця воронка, бачте, посередині…  Ось тут був приліт.
Миколаївська міська лікарня. Місце, де врятували тисячі життів: як військових, так і цивільних.
Були у нас такі хворі, що горіли і в танках, і ті, що підривалися на мінах.
Рятувати пацієнтів доводилося під постійними обстрілами.
На територію лікарні прилітали і російські ракети, і артилерійські снаряди.
Ще не було 5 годин ранку. 7 березня минулого року.
Якраз ми були ще на чергуванні. Між двома цими корпусами був приліт.
Звісно, постраждали фактично всі вікна фасадів наших корпусів.
Попри постійні обстріли лікарня безперервно продовжувала приймати поранених і хворих.
У найбільш напружені тижні опіковий хірург Сергій Смирний жив на роботі.
У нас були епізоди, коли за добу привозили 100, 120 і більше хворих.
І наші відділення справлялись з такою кількістю.
Першу допомогу пораненим надавали просто у коридорах,
а двері до операційної не зачинялися тижнями поспіль.
Це наша операційна на 2 столи. Працювала фактично кожного дня.
У нас було і по 16-17 поранених у відділенні кожного дня.
Найбільше поранених до лікарні надходило під час звільнення Херсона, пригадує Сергій Смирний.
Одним із найважчих пацієнтів був український танкіст, який ледь не згорів живцем у танку.
Танкіст, яким я займався, який провів у нас понад 80 днів,
було зроблено понад 27 операцій, 40 піднаркозних перев'язок, перелито майже 200 літрів різних розчинів.
Відро крові там точно було перелито.
І трошки більше препаратів крові - це плазма, білки. Ми його врятували.
Утім, без втрат не обходилось. Адже часом до лікарні привозили пацієнтів із несумісними з життям опіками і травмами.
Були 60-70-80% і були такі, що всі абсолютно 100% були "згорівші".
Ці хворі, на жаль, померли в дуже короткий час перебування в нашій лікарні.
А ті, про яких ми кажемо 60-70%, то ми боролися_ і такі хворі виживали у нас.
У Сергія й досі перед очима 4 квітня 2022-го року.
Тоді росіяни обстріляли зупинку громадського транспорту.
До лікарні одночасно привезли близько тридцяти поранених, зокрема й дітей.
За життя одного з підлітків боровся Сергій.
Це була в емоційному плані важка робота, бо він був настільки складний,
що ми з цією дитиною навіть і планів не ставили,
бо він фактично в критичному стані був дуже довгий час.
Стан був настільки критичним, що підлітку довелося видалити нирку, проте медики змогли зберегти кінцівку.
Цей хлопець, ми його виписали, зараз він проходить етап
відновлювального лікування на кістках, але дитина ходить самостійно.
Відтоді Сергій слідкує за подальшою долею цього пацієнта.
Тримає зв'язок зі своїми пацієнтами й гінекологиня з Миколаєва Людмила Чинякова.
Добре, Любочка, сонечко, доброго дня тобі!
Восьмий зуб у нас лізе.
Восьмий зуб лізе у дитини, яка народилася завдяки пані Людмилі.
У березні минулого року, коли частина Миколаївщини була окупована,
росіяни не випустили породіллю до пологового будинку.
На той час село під Миколаєвом було окуповане.
Там стояли рашисти. Вони вагітну не випускали.
Звісно, якийсь момент паніки у тих людей був дуже великий.
І потрібно було вирішувати.
Жінка ж не може залишитись вагітною і без допомоги.
Як росіяни могли аргументувати, якщо інакше, як рашистами, це назвати неможливо.
На той час, поки йшли пологи, вони грабували магазин, ганяли танками.
Вперше за понад тридцять років робочого досвіду пані Людмила приймала пологи дистанційно - по відеозв’язку.
Треба було заспокоїти медичну сестру і сказати, що нічого страшного, все буде гаразд, все вийде.
І сама жінка… я дуже вдячна цій жінці за те, що, розумієте… Люба не істерила.
Вона сказала, що справляється. Запитала: "Ви будете зі мною?", а я кажу: "Звісно, буду".
Так народилися здоровий хлопчик Матвій, якому нині вже рік і три місяці…
і дружба - між породіллею та гінекологинею.
Я вважаю, що ми з нею великі друзі.
Вона з радістю приїжджає, вона привозить свого синочка, в неї є ще старший синочок.
Я думаю, що ми ще з нею народимо третього, але тільки у звичайних умовах, у звичайного пологовому будинку.
Російські снаряди і ракети пошкодили шістнадцять миколаївських медзакладів.
Найбільше руйнувань припало на перші місяці після вторгнення РФ.
Жили в підвалах, пологи приймали в підвалах.
Не тільки пологи, а медичну допомогу ми давали в підвалах.
Люди навчилися готувати на роботі. Тобто ми просто жили, просто жили на роботі.
Нині до Миколаєва, за словами Віталія Кіма, повернулися близько 90% жителів.
Медики теж поступово повертаються до звичного робочого ритму.
Приміром, вагітних, яких веде пані Людмила, з кожним місяцем стає дедалі більше.
Люди хочуть бути у нас. Люди звикли до наших умов.
Розумієте, спочатку тут народжувала мама, а потім вже донька народжує в тому ж пологовому будинку.
А там ще й онука буде народжувати. Хочеться бути вдома і хочеться бути на своїй землі.
DW стала свідком радісної події для родини, яка теж нещодавно повернулася до Миколаєва.
Ура, клас!
Буде схожа на маму. Буде Танюшка значить.